the next safe couple is
genie and brandon
jeanie mai cha-chad her way through her
first elimination monday night on
dancing with the stars and her results
were impressive
carrie anne inaudible sex
derek six
[Music]
you know it feels amazing to be
supported by cool fans like it really
you know you you you never want to ask
anybody to do anything for you so we're
sitting here be telling people
vote and enjoy the dance but when you
also put so much work into a dance
and you want to give your heart out make
somebody smile at home
i feel like that that's the reward in it
all you know
another big reward is making her family
proud including her mom who
threatened to send jeannie back to
vietnam if she didn't do well
after last week's show my phone was
blowing up with positive messages
then i woke up and got this message
kenny
this is your mother i want you to do
better okay
much better than the last time all right
otherwise i ship you back to vietnam
i'm just one dance away from being
deported
okay she picked up you're on e.t
with me and brandon what is your advice
for me this week
what were you warning me wow
if you lose you had a loser you have to
go back to vietnam
we don't want to see your face
hey look can i stay can i stay though
wow
right we're the american citizens you're
the immigrant so
all joking aside mom we did really good
that's a mom she looks at your face and
she knows that's right mom
i think i made you proud and although
jeannie says she deserved a better score
she's determined to wow the judges next
week
[Music]
i feel when i
feel inside of me that dance brandon has
told me over and over again when you
really
dance with your heart you feel all the
moves and i'm not saying i don't have
things to work on
but i feel i deserved a better score so
that means that i have to tighten it up
because next week i'm not going to give
them a reason to give me
anything but an improvement